talk at ist austria anna can you go
ahead and share your screen
and she'll be speaking about controller
synthesis
hey i hope you can hear me
yes okay uh
thanks sandra for introduction and
thanks previous speakers
basically you already introduced all the
motivation so
that doesn't require me to introduce
that
i will be talking about controller
synthesis and
in particular how we are trying to
combine controller design
with machine learning how to take
advantage from both worlds
and since there has been already shown a
lot of
examples where machine learning can be
used for robotics machine learning can
be used
for self-driving cars and many other
applications for
perception neural networks can be used
as well
and where is the controller synthesis
that
we are talking about so we have a
controller
here and we have a plant so the control
communicates with a plant
and plant can be in a certain physical
state at every point in time
so this state is read by the controller
and then the controller
it has its goal to choose a proper
action for the plant to continue
to its next state in the next point in
time
so this can be also done using for
example deep refreshment learning if
our specification is a very difficult
optimization problem
or our state space is huge and formal
control synthesis cannot deal with that
then what deep reinforcement learning
will have as a goal
is to maximize expected rewards
so now at each point in time the plant
is in a certain state
and then the controller for each section
receives a reward from the plant
so this kind of controller using let's
say deep reinforcement
learning can be synthesized offline
but then it is deployed and then
online the system can be
in a certain state which agent has never
seen during
training so let's say we synthesized
everything we
produced a nice controller and we
deployed it and now
the agent runs into a state has never
seen that state
so what is the agent supposed to do in
this case
and this is exactly what motivates our
problem this is what motivates to
investigate how formal methods can help
machine learning or in this case deep
reinforcement learning
to be a not only well-performing and
maximize unexpected rewards
but also to be correct by design and
avoid
such stations
so if you would like to learn a little
bit more about how to
synthesize controllers for very complex
optimization objectives based on
optimization then i would recommend this
works that were also done together with
reticlosa
where we in particular investigated
cyber physical systems and how to
synthesize controllers for them
to achieve a certain goal while avoiding
unsafe behavior
and also how to prevent the system
from being a victim of adversary attacks
and how to direct the system to safety
but in this talk i would like to focus
on these two works
done together with my colleagues from
ist
thom hensinger kristen schielen and also
guy avni
and the student that interned with us
and first i will talk about formal
methods with the touch of magic
a bit in detail and then briefly i will
outline our work how we
detect noble behavior in the neural
network using
abstraction taken from formal methods
so let's see the first fork we call it
with the touch of magic
because we consider um the product
of what deep reinforcement learning does
sort of
magic for us because it does something
that is a black box for us
and it does not explain its actions
so we know that deep reinforcement
learning optimizes performance
if we take reactive synthesis for
example
as we've seen what reactive synthesis
does
it takes as given specification for
example in certain logic
and then the goal of reactive synthesis
is to
find a controller that ensures that the
physical plan satisfies this
specification
no matter what happens you can already
see that
reactive synthesis in its classical form
classical formulation does not take
performance
into account while deep reinforcement
learning cannot account for the worst
case scenario
does not provide worst case guarantees
ideally we would like to have a model
that we would extract from deep
reinforcement learning
give it to reactive synthesis and ask
reactive synthesis to follow this model
as closely as possible so that we could
also account for performance while
synthesizing the correct controller
however the problem here is that the
model that deep reinforcement learning
outputs is a neural network
and they are large and uninterpretable
for formal methods
to deal with them instead
we propose to use what we call a magic
book
so a certain magic behind deep
reinforcement learning
would be approximated by another model
closely approximates the performance of
the original agent
but it is small enough for formal
methods to deal with it
and it is also more interpretable
then this magic book can be given to
reactive synthesis
and reactive synthesis would follow the
magic book
as closely as possible when choosing the
actions for the controller
so this is briefly what the framework
does
and an example of such magic book could
be a decision tree
well in our work that i'm presenting
here published in fmcard last year
we we found that
random forest gave the best performance
for
this task that we designed here
so let's see a little bit more in detail
based on the example so let's say that
we had
our deep reinforcement learning agent
which we also call a wizard
because there is some magic behind it
so let's say we have our wizard
how do we get a magic book out of the
wizard
well we observe what the wizard does and
we collect
so-called state action pairs so for each
state that we see
the wizard in we collect what action the
wizard does
then we collect many of those i know
maybe
thousands of those this
gives us a trading data this data we can
use
to train well let's see for simplicity
a single decision tree and this decision
tree would tell us
for each predicate on the state
what kind of action the agent
approximately would take
let's say that there are certain actions
here
and now what we can do with this model
now we have this model here
we can verify it for example we can use
bounded model checking to verify certain
properties of this decision tree
and here's an example of such property
let's say we have a tax on the greed so
taxis here
let's highlight it a little bit so this
is our taxi here
and on this grid the taxi needs to
collect passengers
and the property here that the taxes
never runs into
a loop so we define our state
our state is the position of the tax on
the grid
so this is our taxi and all the
positions
of in this case two passengers
on the same grid these are our
passengers
so when the passenger is collected a new
passenger appears at random point
on the grid and now we would like to do
we would like to write down this
property as constraints
so the constraint for the loop would be
that our taxi
runs into after several let's say
l steps into the same position
as it was before
and for also y-coordinates
and then the same we have to do for
passengers but in this case the
passengers
for a certain number of steps uh do not
move from their positions
so basically um none of them was
collected
so let's say this is our
g
to k and
for a certain number of steps
we see that our passengers
stay in the same position here's why
okay so writing down the property like
this
we can use um bounded model checking to
check if this
if there is a counter example
okay so we've done that now we are sure
that
our magic book is checked so we have it
oops sorry so we have it here again
this is our decision tree
let's say
and there's a certain action well let's
put it here
so now we would like to synthesize the
correct by design control
so how can we do that we design a game
a game on an mdp on the market decision
process
we have two players in this game the
first player is ours the controller
and we would like to win of course and
then the second player
is the environment the adversary however
we
the environment is huge and it would be
very difficult for us
if we do not approximate environment in
any way
and this is exactly where our tree helps
us
our magic book so the
environment the player two chooses
a pass in the stream
and a certain action for a predicate on
the state
and then let's say we've earned this is
our whole state space here
somehow and we know that we are
somewhere here
so then as a player one our
actions would be either we say that
okay we take this advice we take this
suggestion
so we take action a and in this case we
receive a reward one
and we transition to another
state space somewhere here which is
different
or we reject this
suggestion and we take some other action
in this case we receive
the reward zero so this way
we are motivated as player 1
to follow the magic book as closely as
possible
unless it's not possible for
correctness of our control and here in
this figure what i wanted to show is an
example
where we set another property
for our control synthesis after
designing this game
the property that was not there when
deep reinforcement learning agent was
trained
in this case this property is that the
controller
in the taxi has to come back to a gas
station
before the gas runs out so let's say
every
30 time steps it has to come back and we
also put this
wall here the wall that the controller
that the taxi cannot go through while
collecting passengers
and the wall that was not there on the
grid during training of the agent
however what happens here we
um we compared what happens if the taxi
is given this kind of grid and then
if it runs into the wall like this
it is just given a stop sign it kind of
says okay
you cannot go there choose a different
action
in this case what would happen to the
taxi it would just run
around here and not know where the
passengers are
so it will be safe but it will not
collect anyone on the grid
however using the magicbook and
following the advice of the magic book
as you can see here the taxi manages to
overcome the wall
why because it kind of intuitively knows
that there are passengers somewhere
around here in the green
and eventually it follows the advice and
find the passengers overcoming the wall
and this is a very promising direction
for us as well
okay so now let me
show you a bit of numbers so how we
evaluate
such such an approach well first of all
we
try to see as i said we used random
forest here
and we try to see how random force
performs
in terms of this
collecting the passengers on the grid
compared to the original agent
and we see that the performance is quite
similar
and then we synthesize a control that
follows the advice of the magic book
the performance is a bit lower but it's
still good performance
and quite promising and
moreover we can also collect very
interesting counter examples from this
approach
so we can for example say are all the
passengers collected fairly
is first passengers collected always the
first or maybe the second always
collected the first
and collecting these examples we can do
secondary training of our original
wizard
okay so now let's say we designed this
controller
we deployed it in the real world however
there's still a neural network behind it
and the problems can be that the neural
network
might run into completely novel cases it
completely noble images or states it has
never seen
and let's say we have this neural
network here it was trained
to identify two traffic signs nicer road
and the cars prohibited in the area
and now it sees completely novel sign
and you would expect that it would tell
us that it doesn't know the answer to
this question
of cosification unfortunately it tries
to find some similarity with what it
already knows
and gives us high confidence that it
knows this sign
while instead it should tell us it
should warn us
that this is something completely noble
and this is something that i would like
to briefly outline
to you in the next work how we
monitor a neural network using
abstraction techniques
so that we detect such novel behaviors
and this work was published in ikai
conference in last year
so let's say we have the same neural
network and in principle we don't really
care what kind of signs and images are
here
we just say that these are some classes
let's say orange and green
and what we are going to do we are going
to look at the hidden layer
the closest to the output layer because
it's known to be the most explainable in
the neural network
and we're going to collect the output of
this hidden layer
together with the classification that it
is there
in the training data we do this
procedure
offline first so offline
we'll look at the all the training input
of the neural network
and collect the output of the hidden
layer
together with whether it was predicted
as orange by the neural network
or the green and you can see these
points here
these are exactly the points that we
collected from the hidden layer
and then we can build our monitor
and our monitor is a simple abstraction
here in this case
boxes or interval abstraction that we
fit around these points
these are multi-dimensional boxes
then what we do when the system is
already running
deployed we can use this abstraction
to monitor the hidden layer of the
neural network
at the runtime input and see if
something
falls outside the box and this will give
us
an understanding whether something is
novel and then the monitor
will warn the user that there was some
input
and you need to check what's going on
why this abstraction is so good well
because first of all the boxes are very
computationally cheap
and this is a huge advantage for us when
we're working at runtime
secondly we show that it's effective in
detecting
novel behaviors in the neural network
when it comes to
image classification
it is independent of what kind of neural
network structure we have for what data
we use as long as we have
access to this hidden layer
it is very also easy to integrate into
other approaches
for example to look at the threshold of
this confidence here
and other approaches for novelty
detection
and the user can configure how many
warnings they would like to receive or
maybe how often they would like to
receive this works
so this is this performs really well
however imagine the same situation but
this novel
inputs come very frequently and let's
say that you have
a robot that uses a neural network for
perception
and let's say the goal of this robot is
to monitor your pets at home
so it was trained obviously on cats and
dogs and maybe
some toys that you have at home such as
cars
but then what you notice that the food
of your cats
and dogs started disappearing quite
frequently
so you are forced to look into the
neural network to look into the robot
and see whether something went wrong
and what you might find out that an
image of squirrel was identified as a
dog
well you take your neural network and
you retrain it from scratch
now with lots of images of squirrels
such that it detects squirrels
however you notice that the situation
remains
something somebody or something is
stealing the food of your pets
then you look into the neural network
again and again you find a situation
where
something else was detected and not
identified as normal
so you have to do the same very
expensive procedure for training the
neural network
and this is something that we would like
to avoid and i'm not going to tell you
the solution now
but i will just tease you with this
problem there are approaches in machine
learning
that do all kinds of active learning to
prevent this from happening or
online learning stream learning however
there are not many formal methods
that work with this
and this brings me to all kinds of open
problems that still exist
for controllers that somehow have
some learning components in them
so as we already know scalability is a
huge issue
for when it comes to controllers and
learning combined together
so formal methods do not really work
well
when it's a huge dimensionality of
input control synthesis for
partially observed markov decision
process still suffers from
scalability even though it's quite
successful in certain tasks
runtime performance together with
guarantees is a still active area which
is quite open
for investigation and
real-time performance of self-driving
cars unfortunately
still suffers when we would like to
verify them and make sure that they're
correct
and of course what kind of assumptions
we should have
about this real world where we deploy in
our systems
is still still unclear
i presented only a few solutions
only partial solutions to all these open
problems here
such as formal methods with the touch of
magic
and outside the box abstraction
technique
however there are still many questions
that remain and these are just examples
that again i would like to tease you
with these questions to raise some
discussion
for example how can we use model
checkers and counter examples that they
give us
to use them for learning and
how to specify what does it mean for a
counter example to be good for learning
or can we use statistical model checking
for learned controllers
if we cannot use formal methods
maybe we can give some statistical
guarantees but these are only
a few questions and i would really be
excited to
discuss these questions with you and
this is the end of my talk thank you
very much for your attention
all right thank you anna um i think we
are we're running
quite a bit late uh but uh i think
that's okay we should
it's we probably will run about 10
minutes over schedule looks like
uh any questions for anna
i have a question yeah rather go ahead
sure
so when when you make this out of the
box
abstraction so which layers are you
considering are they
the because typically the last layers
are like the
dense layers you have like two two dense
layers at the end
and uh they they make for you the
classification so
are you looking before that uh so
so which which layers or are you looking
at several layers or it's just the layer
before the dance layers that
give you the classification again yeah
thanks for
the that's an important question so we
i've seen in previous works that the
layer right before the
last softmax layer is the the one
where we can get most of the features so
that this is the one that would give us
um the best understanding of what kind
of
features the neural network is looking
at and how the individual the data is
clustered well
but we also looked at the previous
layers and combined
um detections from previous layers as
well
[Music]
but that might be blow up because i mean
there are
like this residual networks you know
that are very good on image.net and they
i mean they started with 16 layers and
you know these
days they have up to thousand layers so
that that might be
probably blow up your your uh state
space
yeah this is true this is true but we we
do not need to look at all the layers so
we just need
some representation of what the neural
network does and usually the last or
maybe a couple of last layers are enough
and that that so you can clearly say
okay i'm out
of all the boxes that i actually knew so
far
so that's uh you get no of course we
we also have false positives fault
negatives for our monetary yes but we
try to minimize that yes but you can see
it
pretty clearly okay it's not something
that we have learned before so
yes yes yes all right
um pretty cool there's one question in
the q a but i hope you can
answer that offline and with that i'll
turn it over to raz buddhic who will